a special Sunday summit cecile brexit
extraordinary in every way
first the --use remaining 27 members
arriving to sign off the Michele Barney
a brokered deal with the PM on an
orderly withdrawal but right from the
off all eyes here on how this goes down
back in the UK and specifically in
Parliament president younger quit work
for Sky News yes well I hope I hope we
said the right stuff give us your
reflection oh you were transmitting what
was said in response after 40 minutes of
what one EU official called a dignified
solemn measured and composed discussion
he was all agreed but this has not been
a quickie divorce Theresa May invited in
to finalise the Accord two years in the
making and around the EU summit table
that she will soon bake eight to start
the crucial process of trying to sell
this deal back home the deal guarantees
a transition period and guarantees the
rights of EU citizens in the UK and UK
citizens in the EU it sets out a
non-binding political declaration about
continuing tariff free trade and there
are assurances of a soft border being
maintained with the Republic of Ireland
but we will pay a divorce bill of around
thirty nine billion pounds by assault of
the PM's mission is creating a sense of
inevitability that there is no other
option that this is the best possible
deal consistent with her negotiation
asks precisely the message conveyed by a
succession of European leaders directly
to British MPs this is the best deal
possible I'm inviting those who have to
ratify this deal in the House of Commons
to take this in consideration this is
the best deal possible for Britain this
is the best impossible for Europe this
is the only deal possible this is the
best deal possible given the
circumstances what's on the table it's
the only deal on the table this is the
deal
I don't think there's anything more the
Prime Minister bracing herself for what
will be Britain's biggest ever sales job
her deal before Christmas MPs will vote
on this deal it will be one of the most
significant votes that Parliament is
held for many years on it will depend
whether we move forward together into a
brighter future or open the door to yet
more division and uncertainty the
British people don't want to spend any
more time arguing about brexit what's
done by her top adviser Oliver Robins
the man who did the deal the Prime
Minister echoed the only deal message to
Sky News Prime Minister do you think
it's helpful that jean-claude juncker
tells mps that it's this steal or No
Deal the point that jean-claude Juncker
was making and that's been reiterated by
authors was that if people think somehow
there's another negotiation to be done
that's not the case this is the deal
it's the result of what is being tough
and difficult negotiations over a
significant period of time and as it's
been said this is the deal that is on
the table this is the best possible deal
it's the only possible deal this is the
moment of history for the Prime Minister
and for the nation to Teresa made trying
to appeal directly to the British people
to come together and get behind this
deal but the only audience that matters
are the MPs have a currently sceptical
House of Commons and if they don't
change their mind it will be history all
right
but of the wrong kind for mrs. May
[Music]
outside the summit a window on the PM's
problem a small but vocal protest of
young remain errs applying a blowtorch
to her withdrawal agreements
and hammering another version for good
measure essentially joining forces with
the hard procedures in her own party
jointly to undermine her agreed deal
heading for the exit door the PM
clutching a signed off deal a
fundamental compromise that she hopes
can bring the country together but which
risks pleading no side at all puzzle
Islam Sky News in Brussels